[Applaus]
eine andere möglichkeit
[Musik]
hätte ich selbst versucht einfach wie
ein echter grosser irrtum zu geben
das ganze komplett ausschlafen und
welches die prüfung auszuziehen
[Musik]
ghana hat mich gesetzt klein gar nicht
ist er durchs video geantwortet ich
dachte mit seinen 440 tausend abonnenten
das also kleine youtuber für mich gar
nicht sieht wie soll ich bloß darauf
reagieren
[Musik]
ich könnte mich über sein äußeres lustig
machen
[Musik]
aber es wäre ganz schön billig billig
der pulli hat fast 20 euro gekostet
haben wir so oberflächlich bin dann
entscheiden sich die zuschauer
vielleicht eher für ihn als für mich
nicht so an musikalisch wäre dann könnte
ich einen disstrack rausbringen
gut man kann einen musikalisch sein und
das track rausbringen ich bräuchte
jemanden mit viel talent damit mein
disstrack einen großen effekt hat einen
großen effekt klar 11880 ja hallo ketten
sie mich bitte mit kenny verbinden
ehrlich gesagt nicht so gut denn dann
hat mich ja gedisst und jetzt würde ich
gern einen song gegen ihn macht man bald
wieder klickt man das hat mir leid ich
wollte so gerne helfen aber aber er aber
ich habe es so viel zu tun gerade selbst
der richter meeresrauschen ist oder
kölner dom im hintergrund war ganz ich
habe es so also sehr viel zu tun bleibe
also das ok power
ach man diese kelly immer nur am
arbeiten warum bin ich da nicht gleich
drauf gekommen
88 ja ich noch mal die nummer von
schlumpfhausen danke hallo hallo du all
das haus nicht
ja der hat bestimmt noch ganz viele
projekte an denen er arbeiten muss
ok letzte chance 88
ja hallo ich bin es noch ein letztes mal
im könnten sie mich vielleicht mit wien
verbindet partie gewohnt sind
ja ich wohne ja zum leben die mich bei
einem distrikt gegen klingt ja ja
woraufhin kalt machen lassen und wie
weit nun schon so ein paar ideen und
glauben heraus ist nicht so richtig
fertig und übertreibt ich zeig dir sage
nochmal wir sichern
klengen gemengen kann du fängst gleich
zu verändern wenn ich mit dir verpasst
man so wird das nichts mit dem distrikt
ich hab's ich frag einfach leute von der
street view fertig machen kann das ist
eine gute idee
entschuldigung ja wissen sie die ich
lenker des lkw lenker spielt der in game
of thrones mit oder entschuldigen sie
bitte wie könnte ich klinge gern wissen
ich denke die kinder wissen
hast du geheime informationen über
klängen entschuldigung kennen wie klein
gern wie könnte ich in dissen den
klängen der hat 440.000 abonnenten auf
youtube machte minecraft
jetzt mal spaß beiseite ich erzähle euch
euren klinken und ich wirklich besser
ich habe dem hai dabei whatsapp
geschrieben ob ähnlich klingen gern
meine nummer geben kann damit wir mal
ein video zusammen drehen können und
dann fing an mir saudi komischen
nachrichten zu schreiben willst du meine
stifter sammlung sehen ich habe sie fast
ein farben und blau habe ich sogar
doppelt und ich hab halt nie drauf
reagiert aber er hat nicht aufgehört zu
schreiben und jetzt hat er halt aus
rache weil ich ihn nicht geantwortet
habe ein video gegen kelly gemacht weil
er damit gedroht haben dann muss ich
halt dieses trends seite video machen
damit ich halt verliert schutz nehmen
kann und clank jak dass das hat mich
geht es nicht einfach kelly dessen kann
nur um mich abzufangen nach dem video
hat er mir dann eine sprachnachricht
geschickt und habe die stimme jetzt mit
verzehrt damit aus
datenschutzrechtlichen gründen das was
sich neckt das liebt sich krank dann
meine ich jetzt ist er auch von soll
alles so falsch zu verstehen und dass
ich nicht in ihn verliebt bin und dann
wurde er richtig sauer und dann kam hat
diese sprache gehört ist klar wenn das
so willst dann wird mein nächstes video
nicht über deine freude geben sondern
über dich ich habe wirklich alles
versucht ich wollte dass er versteht
dass er so mein herz niemals erobern
kann willst einfach nicht
stehen selbst in seinem des video macht
auch sexuelle anspielungen sie hat
gesagt dass ich mich kalt macht und wer
ist milch kalt damit wollte er sagen
dass ihnen ein video heiß gemacht hat
reicht euch nicht noch ein beweis als er
meinen namen die youtube sucht zahl
eingegeben hat stand der x mal hott das
heißt er hatte mal nach mal war doch hat
gesucht in der hoffnung mögliche
nacktbilder von mir zu finden und er
gibt sogar zu dass mit mir ein video
drehen will dass ich war so viele
beweise noch braucht klängen garn ist
nämlich verliebt und versucht nur seine
verletzten stolz zu schützen bitte
glaubt ihm kein wort und wenn ihr diesem
video hunderttausenden herum gibt dann
verspreche ich euch ich zeige euch die
nacht bilder die mit klinker
eingeschaltet auch beim nächsten video
wieder ein wenn ich teste den amazon
spies adventskalender bis dann
[Musik]